[Music]
Clarkson is the active leading scorer 16
points off the bench look at that a
whirling dervish of French Revolution
and the score turned all the way around
and threw it up the window wanted to
pass that ball with lost sight of this
man if you had to just throw it up there
knocks it down yeah you can't give them
that much space marker again has time to
break out the summer league move it's
all the way the bucket shows the defense
the ball nice little double pump and how
about that little English to some print
off the glass it's over the shot clock
is that nice face up in it Tony Parker
Dupin Darrell Arthur great footwork
[Applause]
step through floater over the top of
that Randolph
Cephas gives it up to partner with keen
on the shot clock
Tony
Parker just said substance he did sundry
four paces on one play
well this is a PG proud of her let the
shock didn't affect all the way down
three seconds to go
[Applause]
was it ever in doubt move it to his left
every chance marker again gets to the
paint slips Atari Parker
buckets of hard drives to the basket two
and a half to go in the second quarter
husband at 17 tell me duck in three to
five about the past
Parker
[Applause]
Green slippin defended by Sefolosha it's
Parker
[Applause]
cool
[Applause]
the baseline masses to the pigment
because they're the ones that have been
hurting them with the caca
Parker gets past greenness Bob what's an
end flourish shot by Tony Parker
[Applause]
what an acrobatic shot just watch as he
goes down as he goes down he just gives
it a backflip
[Applause]
still gentlemen
to to shoot
just kataka time
Parker
gets off his feet let's put sanity
that review of to make sure
this marker got it off before the shot
clock expired
it was very very close that looks good
what up at you boy Adam left goats you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report